[Music]
welcome back to science clique
today the mathematics of general
relativity
part 6 energy fluxes
our universe consists of a fabric
space-time
on which we place content stars
mass energy
at first glance the content of the
universe seems very diverse
there are stars planets interstellar gas
clouds
or even living beings like us
yet all this diversity can be summarized
with a single concept
movements of energy
energy is an abstract notion which
indicates the presence of disturbances
in the universe
particular it can arise from mass
mass contains energy according to the
formula e equals
m c squared but
other factors also contribute to the
energy content of the universe
such as the electromagnetic field or
even dark energy
which is known to have negative pressure
in all its forms energy moves through
space
space-time
similarly to a fluid
the presence of an apple for example can
be modeled as a flow of energy
to describe it let's consider a point on
the trajectory
from this point the motion of the energy
can be transferred in different
directions
on a two-dimensional sheet energy can
pass through four different sides
two along each coordinate
[Music]
however the situation is symmetrical if
energy enters the point from one side
it must leave through the opposite side
thus only two surfaces are needed to
fully describe the fluxes of energy
if the apple remains motionless through
space
its energy moves only through time
thus only the surface associated with
time will be crossed by the flow
and if the apple is moving through space
then both the time
and space surfaces will be crossed
for each surface let's represent the
flux of motion which
passes through it by a vector depending
on the behavior of energy
like a sort of fluid these vectors can
vary
breaking them down into their components
we can create a table which contains
these two vectors
this tensor describes how momentum is
transferred along the different
coordinates
we denote it capital t and call it the
energy momentum tensor
in this tensor the first component
measures the amount of energy travelling
through time
this component indicates how much energy
crosses the point
moving towards the future
it's more commonly called the energy
density
it gets greater when more energy passes
through the point
the next two components are equal both
measure how much
energy travels through space over time
this is momentum transport of spatial
motion
over time this value is greater when the
energy moves faster through space
these components are commonly called
momentum density
[Music]
finally the last component in the table
measures how much motion through space
is transmitted through space
this is more difficult to interpret
because we must find a meaning to this
transfer of motion through space
[Music]
this is a tendency that energy has to
push in one direction
it is commonly called pressure
in this two-dimensional example the
table contains
only four components two of which are
identical
but in our four-dimensional universe
this tensor actually contains
sixteen components
it contains the energy density the
amount of energy that progresses towards
the future
the momentum density which is this time
broken down into three components for
each direction through space
pressure which is also expressed along
the three directions
but also a bunch of other terms which
correspond
to viscosity viscosity is the tendency
that
energy has to transfer its motion to its
surroundings
it's important to understand that the
components of these fluxes of motion
depend on the coordinates that we choose
if we change coordinates a motionless
energy
can become a moving energy
in other words motion is relative it
depends on the point of view from which
it is observed
to illustrate this energy momentum
tensor we will look at two standard
examples
the first example is that of an empty
space time
when we calculate it at a point which is
crossed by no
energy the energy momentum tensor is
zero
all its components vanish
this very simple case is fundamental
because it is the one that we will use
most often
indeed when we want to describe the
motion of a small object through
space-time
for example a satellite around earth or
an apple near a black hole
we can neglect the energy of this small
object which is very weak
compared to that of the central body we
can consider that the object is located
in empty space
and the energy momentum tensor vanishes
[Music]
the second concrete example is the case
in which we are interested
in the inside of a body for example
we may want to describe how an object
behaves inside the sun
in this case even if we neglect the mass
of the small object
it is still not in a vacuum because we
have to account for the matter that
makes up the sun
in such a case the energy momentum
tensor is not zero
if we consider that the sun is formed by
a perfect fluid
without viscosity and at equilibrium
then the tensor contains only an energy
density
related to the mass of the sun and the
pressure
directed outwards which prevents it from
collapsing in on itself
[Music]
[Music]
you